crime is on the rise and terrorism has
become an everyday threat to everybody
the police are undermanned underpaid and
under equipped permanently under
pressure any help from any way would
surely be appreciated into the fray step
neighborhood watch
high-end back up to our frontline
services tackling top-level crime or a
bunch of Cardigan wearing morris dancing
busy bodies involving themselves in
other people's affairs which are they
when I went to me a neighborhood watch
coordinator in East London this week she
told me that they were not about
tackling people on the street but more
about creating an aware environment and
she and her fellow residents felt safer
for their efforts I'm all for community
spirit and I'm happy to see people
keeping an eye out for each other as
long as this never escalates to the
point that they become vigilante or
people try bite off more than they can
chew
their long way the curtain twitching
continue you make me jump out my skin
when you do your military voice and can
you imagine if you was a bit of a tea
leaf or something and he was like
peeking round this day it's terrified so
if you're not in there but watch you
should consider signing up because you'd
be a great parent
joking aside I very much agree with you
and I think that one of our problems at
the moment is that we have a real lack
of society and community and I feel like
we operate so often as individuals as
opposed to a collective so when you
think about it and Nick's about
spontaneously combust because he clearly
disagrees with me but what do you think
about you stuff people being brought
together by things like religion that
was their common kind of community and
we're having that less and less now and
when you look at a lot of states people
renting properties and neighbors are
changing frequently and you know even up
north like where it used to be that you
did not like in whole you didn't know
your neighbors and in London you know
less though because it was a lot of
renting and changing and transients I've
noticed in whole people less and less
and knowing who their neighbors are and
people coming and going so actually I
applaud anything that gives back and
creates and in
Hands's and encourages a set of
community and society and brings people
together for the greater good show you
can I'll just show you up I met this
really nice girl breaks right she lesson
this is really cool she's gotta say so
kinda loose once though have a butcher's
at what's actually going on at the sharp
end and this is a product of
Neighborhood Watch chat with this lady
hello my name's Becks and I'm the
extreme coordinator for a local
neighborhood watch scheme in Walthamstow
what help and support to get from the
police do they advocate what you do but
they work hand in hand with Neighborhood
Watch they start off giving you quite
minimal support they tell you the
neighborhood watching the way you run it
is up to you because obviously
nationwide it's very different what
might be interesting for a neighborhood
watch in rural countryside ie a quad
bike might go missing or some livery
from a stable might go astray here is
other problems inner cities have their
own set of significant problems the aim
of my particular neighborhood watch is
to just bring people together to say
hello on the street to make it clear
that you cannot on samus Doris you find
yourself in any sort of trouble or even
if you just want to borrow Africa
so before you tear me a new one Nick all
right
if that woman feels safer for what she's
doing and a few other people do is all
quite quite a few other people do you
know in her case then it's probably good
funding to defer to my new best pal
laughs because Michelle I completely
agree with you by the way has just made
the most powerful case for everything
that Margaret Thatcher who we talking
about earlier did to destroy the things
you described so a destruction of
community lack of social cohesion
privatization the decline of social
housing and then the privatization of
key parts of security that used to
belong to the state and the police now
in the hands of private home ownership
based community groups this isn't a
substitute for society or community and
this is what Margaret Thatcher did
neighborhood watch is response to a
decline of community that masquerades
dramatically increase and Douglas heard
also talked about it as a return to
Victorian values you know this is
exactly what I'm talking about when I
say how much capture it was her policies
that destroyed the kind of communities
you're describing and that's why we need
ideas and watch and it's no substitute
almost real community policing bring us
more with a more recent concept of you I
was with you of course Neighborhood
Watch is a good idea and good luck to
Becks and all the others actually my
house is in a neighborhood watch air and
I think I might even get money off my
insurance as a result so fantastic good
lots of them very very good people but
my concern was you started to get a bit
big society there a bit sort of date of
David Cameron to come to a more recent
our conservative Roma's and that is
where I think he lost but what was the
idea what was the bit the big society
meant absolutely nothing it's a load of
words that delivered nothing
neighborhood-watch do things good for
Bex and her colleagues walking the
streets of Hackney London wherever is
fantastic
big sister I don't quite know where you
want to go talking but what I would say
is the folks that I Rachel's got once
coming to so big Society and all that
hugger who do whatever it was that was
implemented poorly but at the end of the
day when you look now you've got all of
these kids roaming around
on mopeds waving knives guns because
there's no recourse and people are
afraid to tackle them as individuals
which individual is going to go and
tackle this guy on the moped you not but
if there was a collective of you and you
knew that you would tackle this together
then those idiots on these mopeds they
wouldn't be doing what they're doing I
don't know how you can disagree with
that you look like you're furiously
disciplined let my celebration I don't
think that we're talking about
neighborhood watch and policing as if
there are either or they're not they're
complementary to each other and it's
just to me it's common sense it's that
when you have the sign on the tube that
says if that's not your bag you know
report it see it say it's sorted it's
just part of a general awareness that
you know we all have to look out for
each other and it is about tourism you
all right let's have a quick look at an
ad that has been put out about
counterterrorism
[Music]
I mean I wasn't sure what we're supposed
to find suspicious and the man in the
DIY shop now they are closing just they
are closing bricks and mortar police
stations hand over finished so it does
behoove the public to report online or
to wherever they can
a suspicious behavior Rachel my the
important you just summed up the porn
part there for me you might not get what
someone's looking for coming out of it
but sometimes we the very smallest
details at the finest there's the final
things in the puzzles do not mean so
anything that you think is out of place
is worth throwing up the china come on
and that's what these people do an
approach for anybody that does it and I
wouldn't know you know because it is
anyone because I'm not a a what I
thought was it's an embarrassing story
actually a report of what I thought was
a burglary from to my downstairs
neighbors the other day I live in an
area where people do there's been a lot
of crime and people do report it and
they do talk to each other and of course
that's good and okay so my neighbors
invites me to their wedding and I went
and it was lovely in Germany and I came
back and they were still there and then
that night I heard people entering their
flats right so I called the police and
the police came around they were
amazingly came around straightaway they
brought dogs they brought through
enforcement they were easily broke in
the door my neighbors were there in
their pajamas just got back from their
wedding and we had we've been burgled
repeatedly and Notting Hill and actually
the community has now pays I don't
actually because it's a very rich street
around the corner pays for a van just to
go round the next stage security come
and do a job come and bring dogs come
and respond to a lot ok I just say
somebody buzz to break through our
window and my husband is a very messy
man and I said they burgled my husband
study and my mother said how did how
could you tell well we're talking about
policing we do need to tell you the Home
Office have told us the following on
Tuesday parliament approved a
significant settlement that includes the
biggest increase in police funded since
2010 we're providing total funding of up
to 14 billion pounds an increase of up
to nine hundred seventeen million pounds
compared to twenty eight to nineteen
this settlement recognizes the demands
on the police and would enable forces to
meet financial pressures while also
recruiting more officers which doesn't
mean as you rightly say you should do
your bit if you
chemicals you should take that on board
okay everyone now before we go there's
just time for this brexit is less than
two months away there's still no deal we
need all sides to come together and work
to find a way through but unfortunately
that doesn't exactly seem to be
happening this is what Donald Tusk
the president of the EU Council said
this week I've been wondering what the
special place in hell looks like for
those who promoted directed without even
a sketch of a plan how to carry it
safely but never ones to be outdone this
is what Sammy Wilson
the DUP z-- brexit spokesman said in
response this devilish euro maniac is
doing his best to keep the United
Kingdom bound by the chains of EU
bureaucracy and control all he will
succeed in doing is stiffening the
resistance of those who exercised their
choice to be clear of tusk and his
Trident wielding cabal so it seems the
politicians don't want to come together
but we decided will rise above that and
in a spirit of friendship in unity we
are awarding a joint straight talker of
the Week award to both Donald Tusk and
Sally Wilson well we give as good as we
get don't me Nick I think we could
welcome those two to this panel quite
well on a good day of caramel owns know
around we'll get them in what do you
reckon I think it's terrible that
language this is the time yeah of course
this is time for cool heads calm head
some cool words and we didn't see ours
just stone that retro there Vera Singh
and unprofessional and everyone involved
just needs to proceed in a grown-up
fashion have ended on a spirit of
grown-up unity and that's all we have
time for this week but don't forget you
can join in the debate by searching for
the pledge on Facebook or Twitter see
you next time